[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCIS MA: Our mission
is to help developers
like you build a
better app and grow
a more successful business.
DAN GALPIN: Hi.
I'm Dan Galpin reporting from
GDD India for the Developer
Show.
And I'm here with
Francis Ma, and we're
going to be talking about
Firebase Predictions.
So Francis, what's
Firebase Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: Firebase
Predictions is our first step
of taking Google's machine
learning to Firebase,
enables developers
to predict and create
user groups on actions that
users are likely to take.
So for example,
being able to predict
which users are likely to churn
or likely to spend in your app.
DAN GALPIN: How is this
related to Firebase Analytics?
FRANCIS MA: Well,
Analytics gives you
insights on actions that
users have taken in the past.
And Predictions helps you
take it a step further
to anticipate actions
that users are
likely to take in the future.
DAN GALPIN: So why did we
end up building Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: Well, our
mission for Firebase
is to help developers
to be successful.
And one of the feedback that
we've gotten from developers
is wanting to get more
from just analytics,
but also being able to
take more proactive actions
and create more
engaging experiences.
And so we've taken our
machine-learning technology
and patched it up so that it's
much easier for developers
to anticipate, predict, and
to take proactive actions.
DAN GALPIN: What
kind of technology
did we end up using
to build Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: Well, this is
all built on Google's machine
learning, and so we use
TensorFlow under the hood
to make Predictions work.
DAN GALPIN: Does
a developer need
to know anything about machine
learning to use Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: No, not at all.
We have applied the
machine learning,
but have made it in such a
way such that developers don't
need any machine learning
know-how or expertise at all.
All you need to do is
to enable your analytics
and we'd automatically
generate the predictions
based on your analytic events.
And then from there,
you can take actions
using other Firebase products
like Remote Config or Cloud
Messaging, and
you're good to go.
DAN GALPIN: What's the
most interesting use case
you've found for Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
We've seen many game developers
use Predictions as a way
to drive more user engagement.
So for example, creating
user in-app promotions
for users who are likely to
leave their app, to churn.
And so instead of waiting
for users to leave the app
and do the hard work of
trying to bring them back, now
developers can take
more proactive actions
to give them that
offer before they leave
and to continue on to keep
them engaged in the game.
DAN GALPIN: Were there any
surprises about Predictions?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
We've just released
Predictions a few weeks ago
and we're certainly pleasantly
surprised at the amount
of interest we've
seen in this product.
And as I said, since this is
a fairly new release for us,
we're also really excited to
see what developers do with it.
DAN GALPIN: Speaking of
that, how can developers
find out more about using
Predictions in their apps?
FRANCIS MA: We have
all the information
on Firebase.google.com.
DAN GALPIN: Great.
Well, thank you so much,
Francis for talking to me here
at the Developer Show.
FRANCIS MA: Always my pleasure.
Thanks, Dan.
DAN GALPIN: And once
again, I'm Dan Galpin,
reporting for the Developer
Show at TDD India.
You can find out more
about Predictions
at the links in the
description for this video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]